jeder kämpft für sich selbst im moment
nur bier wir krankenschwestern
wir sollen für jeden da sein und das
sind wir auch aber bitte seid vernünftig
seither wir müssen unseren job machen
können und das geht nur mit
desinfektionsmitteln mit dem richtigen
reinigungstüchern denn wir müssen die
räume sauber halten wir müssen unsere
hände richtig desinfizieren können und
wir brauchen masken sonst tragen wir das
virus immer weiter ihr nennt uns helden
aber auch ich habe eine familie und wir
sind immer voller angst
entschuldigt bitte dass ich so weinen es
ist ein hoch emotionales video dass frau
ende reinert dort gepostet hat und sie
ist mir nun auch zugeschaltet guten tag
frau in der rhein hat natürlich als
allererstes die frage wie genau die
situation jetzt vor allem bei ihm auf
der station bei einem krankenhaus ist
wie viele corona fälle haben sie bereits
ich arbeite auf der überdruck station
wir sehen nicht unbedingt so viele
patienten aber wir haben schon viele
gesehen von leuten infiziert sind und in
diesem krankheitsausbruch weiß man ja
auch nicht unbedingt b infiziert ist
wenn jemand ins krankenhaus kommt aber
in unserem krankenhaus in mehrere ja
jetzt haben wir in dem video gesehen sie
sprechen vor allem darüber dass
desinfektions zeug wichtig für sie ist
reinigungstücher was genau fehlt ihm
jetzt alles was brauchen sie eigentlich
um die medizinische versorgung weiterhin
ja richtig ausführen zu können
am hauptsächlich schutzkleidung wir
brauchen kittel wir brauchen masken die
speziellen filter masten im moment haben
wir nur ganz wenig davon
schilder gesicht schilder wir wir haben
wenig desinfektionstücher wir haben
wenig hand desinfektionsmittel es wird
immer weniger weil leute auch mehr
mitgenommen haben kommen zu uns
krankenhaus und nehmen dann die sachen
alle tranken erste müssen einfach sich
vorbereiten dass es schlimmer wird und
und einfach auf den körper bereiten dass
wir keine desinfektionsmittel haben dass
wir keine kette habe dass wir keine
handschuhe haben und wir werden immer
noch korrigieren müssen weil die leute
machen
wenn es kommt zu schützen sind wir ganz
schlecht vorbereitet wir haben viel zu
wenig wir hatten schon vor zwei wochen
nicht genug und jede woche wird der
leute ist immer weniger wir sind da
absolut nicht vorbereitet und haben alle
alle krankenschwestern ärzte sind sind
einfach kann das risiko sich anzustecken
wenn ich die richtige schutzausrüstung
haben